Que en vez de darle 250 millones de euros
a 1 multinacional portuguesa
para contaminar 1 oso país,
que esos 250 millones de euros se utilicen
a desenvolver eh de 1 manera suscible galiza,
y que se aproveche todos esos recursos
económicos para poner en marcha 1 proyecto alternativo,
y más defender que esos 250 millones de euros,
en vez de Dar yo esa multinacional, Altri
se dediquen a o plan
Ulloa Ulla Arousa,
1 plan destinado
a actuar en 3 ámbitos centrales,
o primero
apoyar prospectos económicos de transformación
y apoyo o no somedio rural,
en base a potenciar a innovación y a transformación
de todos esos, no esos productos agrogandeiros,
que sabemos que estas son zonas que tienen
1 amplio potencial en ese ámbito.
A segunda medida de ese plan
eh que se aposte por la recuperación
D.O. río Ulla eh,
por lo tanto
también por la recuperación de arria de Arousa,
que se invierta en mejorar a calidad de da auga,
no podemos, es que ser,
que arria de Arousa
tenga en este momento 1 problema gravísimo de
de productividad,
eh que 1 de las causas eh precisamente
a contaminación y
y que no se está conservando,
ven a calidad de la auga de este río
y a tercera parte,
pues de este plan que proponemos desde ovenegaan
tienen que ver con que se aposte por 1 Nuevo
modelo no ámbito forestal,
donde no solo se Faga
Primera transformación de a madera,
sino que vayamos a 1/2 Y tercera transformación,
aprovechando para desenvolver 1 modelo forestal,
que es ese modelo forestal sostible,
que 1 monte multifuncional,
y donde a clave,
pues esa eh,
que haya 1 mayor transformación de a madera,
no, no so país